men will say like oh
you're dressing for me you're dressing for the male gaze
if you didn't want attention
why'd you dress like that
and like they will truly believe that with their whole little hearts
but the thing is it's kind of true
like I do I do
I do take it into account
but not in the way you think
like I will not wear makeup for men
I will not wear a crop top for men
I will not shave my legs for men
because I wanna send a clear message that I do not wanna be mess with today
I do not have the time today
I don't wanna be perceived by men today
I don't have the energy
and some days I do have the energy to just put up with it
but most days I don't and I will find myself dressing sluttier than anything
if I am going to a safe queer space or a safe female dominated
like the girls the gays
the gays space that's when I will be my skankiest
so in a six side way they're kinda right
but also just like so so wrong
there is truly no greater compliment than a gay man saying that you're hot
like I will truly not consider a compliment
a compliment from a straight man
it goes over my head but if a gay man
there is nothing better in this world than a gay man or a girl saying
that you're pretty I still have a catalog of all the compliments
in my head that I've ever received from gay men
I could list them out now to you
I won't but I I
I could but I could not tell you a single compliment
that I've gotten from a straight man
in fact I could list off some nagging cause that lives rent free in my head
but not a single compliment
it just not
cause I haven't gotten one
but because obviously
but because they don't mean anything they don't stick